posez-vous la question quelle est la
plus grande qualité
de votre de vos proches de votre proche
par exemple moi la plus grande qualité
de ma mère c'est
que soit son fils
non mais voilà donc posez-vous les
questions posez-vous ces questions par
exemple voilà toi c'est quoi ta plus
grande qualité et écoute c'est pas le
goût
c'est discutable hein les goûts et les
couleurs bon mais non mais je dirais le
gentillesse
normalement tu es gentil c'est vrai quoi
c'est quoi ta plante la fidélité
[Applaudissements]
il y a toujours pas d'électricité chez
lui c'est pas possible ça pique dans le
noir le gars il y a rien qui va ensemble
merci
même si par exemple je ne vais pas bien
je ne vais pas l'imposer aux autres
je trouve que c'est un peu commentaire
[Rires]
Géraldine moi je serai généreuse
généreuse générosité généreuse oui c'est
vrai
[Applaudissements]
c'est bon là les menteurs de ce côté-là
les mythos c'est bon
faire un demi-tour même un bon petit
n'importe quoi
chercher ton mec à l'école
[Applaudissements]
Jacques je pense la loyauté ah je
t'embrasse
la loyauté voilà prenez-en de la graine
la loyauté longtemps je t'égardé comme
une perle rare merci toi je sais moi je
sais aussi ta qualité tu as
principalement
je me sers d'une situation où qui a
quelqu'un qui a pris
sa qualité mais je suis pas généreux je
suis pas courtois je suis pas sympa je
suis une tête de con je vais pas vous
dire
dans les soirées j'arrive à faire partir
en fou rire la soirée
je suis pas maître des mots sur ce que
tu veux
[Applaudissements]
mais franchement les gars je me tue elle
est payée mais c'est des vidéos parce
que vous vous aviez de qualité
[Rires]
conduit bien j'adore ok bah reviens
reviens sur ta plus grande qualité la
prochaine fois qu'on te demandera c'est
drôle d'accord
rien de raconter
moi ma qualité c'est que j'aime l'amour
j'aime l'amitié j'aime donner j'aime
recevoir et j'aime les gens c'est
[Rires]
j'ai déjà dit la modestie persévérance
et bien sûr l'humilité
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on va parler on va parler après
[Rires]
par contre toi au niveau du français
[Musique]
même moi je l'ai trouvé il est toujours
à côté pareil attends c'est pas possible
alors quelle est ta principale qualité
Pascal la joie de vivre l'optimisme
[Rires]
ta présence bordel tu as la prestance
mais non elle est là voilà c'est ça
principal qualité je sais pas grand
chose exactement
[Rires]
c'est quoi le sens de la mesure
revient tu vas faire peur aux pigeon
dehors
[Rires]
on a encore besoin des pigeons non mais
c'est rigoler c'est vrai la dernière
fois j'ai vu un pigeon qui se battait
avec un rat mais on voit des chaînes
maintenant dans Paris
j'ai appris qu'il était interdit de
sauver un pigeon à Paris non
[Rires]
j'essaie de sauver des pigeons il y a de
plus en plus de pigeons qu'on voit
écraser
et on m'a dit oui on m'a dit que que
j'étais hors la loi vous avez accouché
un pigeon
ça se dit c'est une bonne info
très vite maintenant vous savez quoi tu
en prends je vais prendre l'un d'entre
vous et chacun va devoir donner un
défaut sur lui
ce sera au hasard c'est bon et votre
chance
Gilles
un défaut de Gilles allez-y même si ce
qui est dur ça même ceux qui viennent de
le connaître Guillaume son ignoble veste
son côté larbin ça contradiction
arrête
son absence de sens de la mesure parce
que il dit n'importe quoi
moi je parle pendant l'émission donc
je préfère fermer ma gueule que dire des
conneries comme toi à longueur d'onde
[Applaudissements]
ici c'est une famille vous faites partie
de la famille des séries merci d'être là
et ici tout le monde sait tout le monde
se dit des gentillesse
de son défaut moi je dirais que c'est
ses idées mais j'ai découvert un homme
depuis que je suis ici
et voilà et donc j'ai découvert un homme
que je ne connaissais pas donc ces idées
parce qu'à part ça il est très bien
d'accord Jacques
j'ai l'impression que tout a été dit
côté solitaire
et quand je sais pas on est tous là haut
puis lui il est en bas il est solitaire
ah moi j'aimerais qu'on fasse tous ces
défauts tous ces qualités